he is the head coach of Texas Tech Chris
beard on the show how are you coach I'm
doing good thanks for having me a
pleasure to have you on what's going
through your mind right now what's
what's coursing through your veins
getting set to go to Minneapolis at the
final 14 yeah I'm actually kind of
obsessed with one idea just how in the
world are we gonna score one basket
against Michigan State is that it get
your genuine concern yeah they're really
good obviously but uh you know watch
them as a fan for years just game after
game but now kind of digging in you
understand what they're all about
they're just really good simply stated
yeah well I mean my concern it this way
when you're concerned about scoring a
single basket I know how it feels I know
the sensation coach because I had that
feeling watching my team go against
yours last Thursday night what were you
what did you see in Michigan that you
were able to exploit so expertly last
Thursday night
yeah I don't know if we exploited
anything but you know our guys had so
much respect for mission going into the
game so from a coaching standpoint there
was zero need to motivate or enhance how
tough a game it would be our guys were
locked in I think we were they just pass
the eye test for so many gritty good
players and a greatcoat so we just
thought we know we had to play team
basketball they had so many individual
pieces on that team that we really
wanted to try to dis emphasize team
defense every time down the floor and so
I thought our guys did about as well as
you possibly could we were fortunate
they missed some shots I think you got
to give our guys credit goes for the
most part most of the shots were
contested I'm the first to give you
credit I mean that that was the best
defensive performance I've ever seen
with my two us
it honestly coach I'll be honest I
thought at one point because there were
times where Michigan turned your team
over that I thought in the transition
game there were six Red Raiders on the
floor there wasn't a single I had to
count I'd literally did count at one
point to see if you had an extra person
on the floor because of the way that
your team drops back and plays shut down
certainly on the perimeter
how do you teach that how does that get
taught you know our identity we try to
recruit to D sentence we spend the
majority of our time every day in
practice on it um but we just kind of in
our DNA you know that you gave our
players a lot of credit we had multiple
guys on the all-big 12 defensive team
and it's just who we are
Chris beard Texas Tech head coach here
on the Rich Eisen show what influenced D
does Bob night have in your coaching
style right now a lot I mean my it's my
years with coach nari Pat you know we're
special like said earlier this week it's
just so true as I given a PhD every day
knowing coaching whether it be in
practice or the meetings or you know
just watching coach and pat on and off
the court so you know I'm really proud
of my association with cokes tonight I
think you know at the top of that list
all of our guys graduated you know I
thought coach did this at the highest
level about as good as you can possibly
do it over many many years and you know
three different institutions I think
most people associate a success at
Indiana which is understandable but you
know we had a really good run here at
Texas Tech three NCAA tournaments and
sweet 16 you know coach won a lot of
games here too as well and he did you
hear from him over the weekend I have
not heard probably the last couple of
days but he's been great actually heard
from actually from Big Bite though this
morning on a event that he's doing in
May for the Jimmy B Foundation and he
had mentioned he talked to coach maybe
even earlier today and coach said some
great things about our team so he's been
like unbelievably supportive since we
came back to Lubbock and um it's just
been a blessing you know having him
around we got one of coach's former
players Darryl doors a graduate
assistant and their staff working
towards his master's degree and Darryl
stays in touch with him often but coach
has been nothing but supportive and what
who have you heard from that you were
surprised to have heard from
he had the cool question no he's kind of
different people like I mean one example
of many coach Charlie Strong you know a
great respect for him really started
following his teens when he was coaching
football at Texas and they've kind of
become this kind of text message type
friends with him and he reached out but
it's really cool just to really hear
from you know the people that that you
kind of respect what they do you know
another example be Dez Bryant you know
big 12 guy hasn't played at Oklahoma
State he said some great things about
our teeny last couple days so March is
special for so many reasons but you know
to hear from some people that you
probably wouldn't hear from on a normal
Monday is pretty cool yeah Dez Dez hit
you on your on your phone he didn't hit
me personally but he's been really
complimentary of our team and I think
our guys are kind of in the process of
trying to reach out to Chris beard few
more minutes with the Texas Tech a head
coach here on the Rich Eisen show you
you came into the tournament off of a
shocking loss to West Virginia
did that help do you think that helped
your team um yet to be determined you
know our goal has always been to get to
Monday night and then try to play our
best game of the year on that Monday
night so I think if we're fortunate
enough and it's really easy to talk
about but almost impossible to do but if
we were fortunate enough to give
ourselves a chance here in these next
two days then yeah it would be a big big
fan of getting beat every year in the
tournament first game big 12 when's the
first time you laid eyes on Janet Culver
coach um I'd know to Culver uh you know
he's from Lubbock and obviously I lived
here love it for a long time and when we
were coaching at Arkansas Little Rock we
saw him on the circuit knew he was going
to be a high major recruit so he didn't
recruit him at Little Rock but I was
aware of him he was the first phone call
we got when we made when we came to
Texas Tech first recruit first phone
call in the whole deal but I've known
about it for a long time you know
haven't lived here in Lubbock
there's a deal called bells and Mo's or
something like kids and love it you know
go to some kind of formal and stuff when
they're little but I want to say that my
oldest daughter
through the freshman at Columbia
University right now in New York City
hmm I think she grew up with Jarrett in
the same kind of timeframe now they
weren't classmates or any things I think
there's a bellows in both dance at some
point where Jake older was there the
same day my daughter was and I gotta get
a picture that if anybody's out there
and love it's listening I need that
picture I'd send it right your way
that's that's awesome that's funny
what about other than just this team
your your future obviously got a couple
years left in your contract there's a
lot of conversation about you and what
you have been able to do Oh
what can you tell us on that front right
now coach oh it's always it's a real
easy question for me to answer you know
I'm just to get it just really enjoys
you know every day and I know it kind of
sounds cliche but it's really what's you
know been a big part of my past and
really all of our coaching past you know
I was four or five years ago I was
coaching schools that you've never heard
of but still having the time of my life
and um you know basketball is everything
I just try to kind of approach each day
and live it out to its full and sweet we
tell our guys all the time and enjoy the
ride not just the destination so that's
certainly what we're trying to do this
week is as well no obviously if you want
to expand your horizons we've seen your
fireside chats on Facebook coach I'll be
honest with you as a broadcaster I'm
here in the footsteps I'm here in the
footsteps of what you've been able to do
who is your inspiration in these
fireside chats that you that you host I
think a little bit of everybody above
and all like so so I think they're
detectives we're trying to connect with
our student body and we had an idea
about a year ago is there any way we
could kind of just reach out to them on
social media once a week and then
somebody floated the idea a fireside
chat around the office so but it's been
a lot of fun it's really connected us
with our students mmm
we've had a lot of fun with it it's
important the best things we've done
this year in terms of increasing
attendance and awareness of basketball
and love it's been off yes I mean
you're a natural laughs you know mommy's
saying I think you're really good you
know what we pride ourselves in mostly
as we call it one take you know we've
never done such as taking those oh
that's got us in trouble from time to
time right just with some inaccuracies
Oh signs that Dillon politics or they
check everything you say and see if it
was just me
if the fireside was ever checked on the
statistical facts we might be in trouble
but we do take a lot of pride in being a
one-take operation well there's no
do-overs in sports I mean you're a coach
you know that so exactly 1 take 1 take
coach that's the way it's only got to be
I mean you can't just do it over again
yeah that might be next year excuse you
you know I go this reveals a fireside
chat koozies all the students in the
mixture might be fireside chat there are
no do-overs there are no do-overs ain't
look if that's the way it goes I don't
want any cash out of it okay I just want
I just want just just a little bit of
credit that's all that's all I'd want
just a small bag that's the least we
could it we'll send you a couple dozen
of the cooties hey it's the least and
and I will have several several beers in
that koozie to drain away the sorrows
that you helped create in the sweet 16
game for me and all my michigan friends
yeah speaking of beers somebody's asked
me this morning about you know just the
final four and so like I've been really
fortunate these last couple years with
these jobs you know that they pay so
well all of my buddies you know we meet
at the Final Four every year some of my
Chico friends d24 and Evert you know
everybody I picked up the tabs the last
couple of years so this is like a
win-win you know our team gets to play
in the Final Four and I don't have to
pick up ridiculous tabs with everybody
well and that's great especially since
if you can get a further contractual
status out of this and also save on the
bar tab I just you did drop that your
daughter goes to Columbia so you
definitely you know it's good exactly
hey coach Congrats on everything that's
going on - Elite Eights in the final
four in your first three years on campus
they're just all sorts of good stuff
congratulations thank you very much you
bet thanks for calling and that's Chris
beard touches tech head coach the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience